well welcome everybody it's a real
privilege and pleasure for me to be here
today introducing John Donne to give the
Stimson lectures for 2011 these are the
distance election series is a venerable
lecture series that has gone has
produced some important books that have
been published over the years by Yale
University Press just to mention a few
of them Samuel Huntington's political
order in changing society some people
think was his best book which started
out as Stimson lectures Tom and Thomas
Schelling's which which Schelling book
was it I forget which schelling book it
was actually but one of Tom Thomas
Schelling's books on on game theory and
and strategy started out as Stimson
lectures and most recently Marwan washes
the Arab Center the promise of modern
modernization a very important book
particularly timely given what's going
on in the Middle East right now so as I
said these these are very lectures with
a history and we're very very fortunate
today to have John Donne giving the
Stimson lectures these are going to be
four lectures beyond the democratic maze
over the next two weeks the title of
today's talk is diagnosing democracy's
power his second lecture understanding
democracy's ascent will take place
tomorrow at the same time in the
auditorium downstairs next week on
Tuesday and Wednesday he'll lecture on
recognizing democracy's disorientation
and finally recovering our bearings
fatality choice and comprehension I'm
not I'm not known for long introductions
I'm work on the assumption that nobody
came here to listen to me but came to
to the speaker but I do want to take a
minute to say something about John hi
he's one of the most interesting and
creative political theorists writing
today I've always been a great admirer
of his I first came to know of his work
because of his tremendously important
book on John Locke's political theory
which completely transformed Locke's
scholarship for general for I would say
generations certainly four cohorts as we
might say in the political theory trade
in that he and he unearthed the
importance of the religious dimensions
of Locke's writings and completely as a
result changed the way we think about
have not only locked but 17th century
English political theory much more
generally
since then he's written a very prolific
writer on many subjects another one of
his particularly arresting books I think
was a book that I first came across as
an undergraduate Western political
theory in the face of the future in
recent years he's written more and more
and more about democracy not only from
Anglo dimensions but a very good recent
book that explored the French roots of
democratic theory and recently he's
become more and more interested as I
have learned from conversation and I
think we're going to learn more about in
in these lectures about conflicts over
and pressures toward the creation of
democracy in Asia in the Middle East and
elsewhere but that's for John to talk
about not for me and so I will live up
to my promise of short introductions and
welcome you John and thank you for
coming we look forward to hearing from
you
you
through the harm it was doing to them
then it was also at that point that it
once again is now inflicting massive
collateral damage on the enduring human
interests of America's own citizens it
matters very greatly how the citizens
and political elites of this country
apprehend democracy what it means what
it causes in the world what was required
for it to come into existence in the
first place or persist with any security
it matters for huge populations of which
they know almost nothing and because it
matters so much for those it's long
mattered and he's going to go on
mattering for you and your children
after you and your children's children
as far as the eye can see so why does
this word now hold such singular
political authority where is the power
that works so strangely within it what
exactly is it that modern populations
are consenting to subject themselves to
in accepting democracy's sway you can
hear that question in a number of
different ways and try to answer it
accordingly in this lecture I'll try to
do so by retracing in outline the story
of how it one that ascendancy sorry in
my next lecture I'll try to do that but
today I want first to get a grip on a
prior issue what the ascendancy itself
really consists in I think that's a
two-part question in the first place
what exactly is it that is in the
ascendant in democracies sway what what
is democracy and secondly what is it
about democracy that equips it to
establish and sustain that sway what is
in the ascendant is quite elusive in
content but easy enough to recognize in
form in essence it's a formula for
imagining subjection to the power and
will of
without sacrificing personal dignity or
voluntarily jeopardizing individual
family interests the standing of any
such formula is necessarily precarious
in political use since subjection itself
detracts painfully from dignity in the
first place and rationally precludes
complete assurance over the protection
of any interests at all you can see the
imaginative pressure on the formula at
once if you simply call to mind the fact
that 300 years ago virtually anywhere
where the word democracy might possibly
have been written or spoken it was
extremely close to being a synonym not
for good but for bad government it may
perhaps have been a bit strident to
claim that democracy 300 years ago was a
pariah word as my friend Quentin Skinner
pointed out to me with some asperity
when I did call it that democracy did
even then after all elicits a measure of
respect on one prominent occasion from
the unlikely figure of King Charles the
first
if admittedly under acute and unusual
political pressure but no one could
mistake King Charles's sponsorship for
unequivocal endorsement the point he
meant to concede wasn't that democracy
on its own was a sufficient condition or
even a helpful contribution to ensuring
good government but rather that
democracy painstakingly inserted into a
highly constraining structure of
countervailing power could contribute
something distinctive to the mix of
benefits which mixed government
government that combined elements of
democracy with usually rather more
salient and consequential elements of
monarchy and aristocracy as well could
be trusted to supply and that under
those constraints democracy could supply
that benign supplement more dependably
than unmixed monarchy or
adults wretched aristocracy could be
relied on to that special additive as
Charles identified it in his celebrated
answer to the nineteen propositions in
1642 was Liberty a term of great
ideological resonance in England's
lengthy history and a value that no
English monarch could safely align
themselves against it wasn't an anodyne
concession to politeness by a ruler in
any case not noted for his tact since
there are grounds to see Liberty in that
rich diffuse English sense as a fair
counterpart to the freedom which the
Democrats of ancient Athens viewed as
the principal benefit of their own
democratic way of political life and
since the political setting in which the
liberty of democracy featured in
England's governmental structure was the
elected House of Commons which Charles
had painstakingly prevented from meeting
for over a decade precisely in order to
free himself from its harassment and
obstructions for Charles himself
whatever else might be in doubt about
how best to govern England what was not
in doubt was who was entitled to govern
it who was the sovereign and who must
submit themselves to being governed who
were the subjects it was he who was the
sovereign and every other native-born
person in the kingdom who with the
subjects and the gulf between the two
was categorical and unbridgeable as he
stood on the scaffold nearly seven years
later in January 1649 he insisted for
the last time truly I desire their
liberty and freedom as much as anybody
whomsoever but I must tell you their
liberty and freedom consists in having
of government those laws by which their
life and their goods may be most their
own it is not for having a share in
government sir there is nothing
pertaining to them a subject and a
sovereign
our clear different things now that
isn't a tone we're still accustomed to
here in the English language
still less the American but at any
moment when sovereignty is located and
applied Charles was certainly right then
and he must be still just as right today
as he was in 1649 even though by that
year his own argument had turned
brutally against him seeing from the
receiving end
what sovereignty asserts requires and
imposes just is subjection whenever it
no longer dares to assert or impose
subjection sovereignty itself has
vanished away and not just been parceled
out into a miscellany of vaguely
demarcated jurisdictions as with any
purposes it obviously now is subjection
is an inherently distasteful and
degrading condition and most
disconcertingly so at the point of
incidence that where it's applied the
special and enduring earner of democracy
in competition with other regime titles
isn't that it better ensures the service
of the interests of the citizens are
very complicated and elusive causal
calculation across time and space
precariously related to regime form and
one in which it often comes out quite
badly where the early or lies is in the
reconciliatory offer of the chance to
assume subjection for yourself and share
on notionally equal terms in selecting
the person or persons who is going to
deploy it it's hard and also sometimes
wrong not to be suspicious of this
reconciliatory promise not to see it
quite often in practice largely as a
mirage a vision of water in the desert
where the water unfortunately isn't
there but the water itself isn't real
enough need what's illusory
is where it appears to be almost within
reach any theory of sovereignty any
conceivable way of imagining and
interpreting what it consists in why
it's there when it is there and why in
some form or other it's genuinely
required is going to over authorize in
practice it's going to endorse far more
claims than carry any critical validity
it will license more power in only
untrustworthy hands than a steady vision
of what's going on could possibly
sanction democracy is no exception and
American democracy no more of an
exception than any other national
interpretation or experience of
democracy indeed American democracy's
greatest claim to historical distinction
it's impressive longevity and spatial
amplitude themselves guarantee that it
must have encompassed as it certainly in
fact has a huge range of access
authorization of the outcomes of
sovereign choice if you want power and
if you were tame it on any scale you
can't also hope to elude responsibility
every sovereign state per speak Presley
has blood on its hands the older and
bigger all but inevitably the more in
purely analytic terms there's no reason
to attribute Democratic sovereign over
authorization to any special
speciousness lurking in the category of
democracy itself
I've got may wish to defame democracy
their little inclination to shield it
from any infamy it earns in use but all
of us for the present at least in
countries to any degree resembling this
one a caught up in the distinctive
imaginative perceptions of democracy and
exposed more deeply than we can possibly
realize through its particular prevents
that
to over authorized and distort political
and moral orientations as it does say
sovereignty answers to a need on the
part of its subjects but it can only
respond to that need by removing from
them sooner or later
any rightful responsibility to judge for
themselves how's the sovereignty itself
is to be exercised democracy in any
defensible understanding any
interpretation that isn't explicitly man
daesh's restores that right and
responsibility however fleetingly to
every citizen at least and leaving to
them the choice over who exactly is to
judge how the sovereignty is to be
exerted they personally authorize
however unwillingly or inadvertently the
judge or judges and their own judgment
therefore figures explicitly in the
terms of their subjection just how
legibly it so figures and quite how
accurately it calibrates and enforces
their judgment is open to serious
dispute in any possible institutional
rendering of democracy and is in fact
actively disputed in almost all
decisions under democracy in which the
citizens between them particularly care
about the outcome it's not
characteristic of democracy as Plato and
Hobbes both definitively pointed out
that it's reconciliatory offer of
inclusion is reliably experienced in
practice as either soothing or
normatively unerring seen from that
angle
the reconciliatory benediction of
democracy looks a very poor bargain and
all but vacuous gesture in return for a
diss mainly complete alienation of
autonomy this country in particular it
violates the intimations of a remarkably
wide range of sensibilities from the
county and elevation of devotion to
equality of respect for every member of
an orphan
vividly unedifying species to the surly
defiance of governmental intrusion into
any sphere beyond the defense of life
limb and personal property to see just
why the democratic bargain has come to
be so widely accepted in this of all
countries and why its acceptance here
has come to seem to so many a good
reason to believe it uniquely eligible
for the rest of mankind it's necessary
to see three elements in close relation
to one another in the first place the
drastic need for government which arises
out of the practical economic and social
organization of the human world as it
now is in the second place the orbit
complete exhaustion of all rival or
earlier reconciliatory formula for
motivating the acceptance of subjection
and thirdly but every bit of
consequential the degree to which
there's an acceptance of subjection in
practice is inauthentic provisional
insincere or impatient and always open
the decisive withdrawal that
psychologically is how a citizenship now
is and very plausibly how it always has
been and was always bound to remain if
citizenship then that that third element
in the bargains constituents is BAPS
intuitively obvious and always
recognized at least tactically by
everyone
though it certainly conflicts sharply
with what most of us care to be heard
saying you could say that it's the
Democratic counterpart to prerogative or
reason of state the unstated intention
to breach our own personal version of
the social contract whenever we deem fit
in that sense that tacit contract with
it's understandably tacit reservations
is indeed in the memorable phrase of
Robert Nozick not worth the paper it's
not written on what grounds the third
element plainly is the prospectively
massive
personal inconvenience sooner or later
of cleaving to the contract in onion
village circumstances consideration with
the neom he imagined to reach almost
anyone but the grounds for the first two
elements couldn't be imaginative the
immediate in quite the same way in the
midst of militant anarchy in downtown
Mogadishu or the vast hellhole of the
eastern reaches of the Democratic
Republic of the Congo the need for
government is apparent enough but the
prospect of its effective supply in any
form which it would be sane to trust is
utterly implausible the currency of
democracy as a regime name today must be
understood in settings where relatively
effective government already exists and
not where it's conspicuously absent or
on the premise that democracy is a
political idea or any institutional
embodiment of that idea might themselves
hold the causal capacity to usher
effective government into existence
anywhere at all the idea of vindicating
the authority of any particular claimant
to governmental power by underlining the
pressing urgency of the need for some
form of effective government Hobbes's
great idea
wilts in political practice just where
it's needed most where the government is
of limited efficacy and faces at least
some immediate challenger with vivid
appeals to some of those it needs to
govern more effectively once an
incumbent government faces serious
insurgent challenge obvious trail of
thought ceases to discriminate
decisively between the Challenger and
challenged and differentiates evermore
feebly between them as the challenge
rises in intensity
whatever the imaginative value of seeing
democracy as a cheaper functional
surrogate for civil war it can't in
itself furnish a reason for shifting
allegiance within such
war or lessening the effort to secure
victory for the side towards which you
yourself happened to feel allegiance
just as democracy can't accept by
providential accident vindicate the
territorial scope of any given state it
can only serve to identify the
legitimate rulers of además the people
which already views itself as a people a
distinct body of human beings who belong
decisively together but supposing a
government duly available and
territorial perimeter and civic
membership each settled at least
temporarily whether by common consent or
through political or military exhaustion
it isn't difficult to see how democracy
on its own can help to reconcile a
population to its need to continue to be
governed effectively why after all
should any population be willing to
reconcile itself not to being governed
at all but to be to be governed by those
who currently happen to govern it
populations can accept subjection
following Max Weber or at least three
very different bases they can accept
subjection because they see themselves
as having good reason to accept it
within a framework of practices
presumptively composed of good reasons
the whole way through an optimistic
vision of a process which has been
running hard for some little time in
societies in which most of us live they
can also accept subjection instead out
of or a condition less frequently
encountered nowadays not least in the
United States and perhaps never
overwhelmingly common or very protracted
ly sustained anywhere at all or in the
third place they can accept it simply
out of habit because they've done so
protracted ly already and can barely
imagine doing otherwise or have simply
forgotten how to all three bases for
accepting subjection tradition charisma
rationality have obvious elements of
Karia sness few civil wars of any
violence in a globalized capitalist
world are likely to leave tradition in
good working order because civil war is
highly disruptive of habit the longer of
the fiercer the nastier the more
disruptive charisma
however amplified by modern techniques
of mass long-distance impression
management and media control is a
wasting asset there it continues to
punctuate the political history most
countries at whimsical intervals where
democracy has inserted and established
its legitimate or eise way has been
within the historical domain of
relatively well settled government in
largely pacified states situated within
a dynamically globalizing capitalist
economy one natural way of seeing just
why it's done so in that setting is to
review its arrival in classical mode as
the replacement of two obsolete and
inherently implausible if reasonably
reasonably concrete and determinate
claimants to ruled a monarchy or
presumptive aristocracy or oligarchy of
some kind by a third residual claimant
with no special plausibility in itself
always manifestly incapable of ruling as
and by itself on any scale and hence in
need from the outset of a mystification
proxy to do it's rule for it and one
which would thrust the issues of
entitlement or capacity to rule beyond
any possibility of cognitive
accountability where monarchs or
aristocrats can no longer as Lenin put
it go on in the old way who is left to
try to do so but everyone else the
people in its full sovereign in
definition that's what you see if you
view democracies of sent as the triumph
of one form of government over two of
its historically protracted be disasters
and that historical sequence is indeed
unmistakably there in the record but
what would be ingenuously be to take
that historical sequence as self
explanatory or interpret its outcome
though silently on its own terms if we
press the question of why the demon Marx
who plainly can't now a rule in the
United States or anywhere else are less
implausible claimants to do so than
they're decisively ousted predecessors
the answer can't simply be but they are
so much harder to get into clearer focus
or keep in focus where you fleetingly
succeed in doing so forms of government
aren't free-standing institutional
structures which stand or fall with the
identity and socio-economic properties
of those who inhabit them there are also
always elaborated imaginative proposals
certainly embodied in complex
organizational arrangements and staged
by varyingly active human denizens but
extensively dependent throughout for
their stability or vulnerability on the
inherent imaginative plausibility of
what they're proposing the most
consequential and elusive political
property of the United States over a
hundred and seventy years since
Tocqueville second volume is still the
imaginative force of its own distinctive
interpretation of the basis on which the
demos it's very own people exercises is
all but unchallengeable rule in the
United States by now that basis has
become indistinguishable from tradition
it's been so for a long time it can
still blaze into charisma briefly at
particular historical moment and it
furnishes the dense web of legal
rationality or rational legality that
makes up the nation's public life it's
all things to all persons and almost all
the time
but in most of the rest of the world by
contrast democracies sway where it's
been exercised at all has been much
briefer far less secure and vastly more
heterogeneous in its imaginative
rendering it's had to penetrate much
thicker armor and it's had to struggle
to bring to order far more turbulent
spaces it's faced rivals to its rule who
were far more affordable formidable from
the outset and those rivals have come
far closer at some points to crushing it
definitively it's never felt for long
that it was living a charmed life and
yet it is democracy at the third of this
simple Greek triad of governmental forms
which has somehow or other won through
up to the present as mandatory basis for
interpreting the authority of government
across most of the world why ever should
that have turned out to be so it
certainly can't be because of long gone
green brilliance captured in vocabulary
like a fly in the amber and the reason
why it can't isn't merely because it
would be impolite or transgressive to
say set the true answers to many urgent
questions throughout human history have
always been somewhat impolite and quite
often bhrastika leah transgressive as
well in ancient greece democracy wasn't
the stable majority outcome of the
competition between forms of government
for Greek communities even left to their
own devices it couldn't have been so
because there was no stable outcome and
no one could readily mistake the
relative eligibility of democracy for
the clear conclusion of consecutive
rational thought conducted in Greek
across the Classical period if democracy
in its equivocal contemporary sense has
recently shown itself the fittest
survivor in competition between forms of
government across the world a verdict
like all Darwinian Verdi
permanently open to reversal that
necessarily provisional outcome can't be
due to the epistemic for the city-owned
or interpretive wealth lurking in that
simple Greek triad or the vocabulary
that expresses it where it must lie
isn't something quite different and
decidedly less reassuring the
imaginative potential for identification
left fully open by the third term of the
Triad democracy since that potential is
left so fully open it can scarce be in
principle have democracy can scarcity in
principle have any elective affinity
with either law or reason law because
it's so pervasively there at least in
any modern society and because that very
presence must at any point stand so
clearly over against the immediate will
of any particular persons it's still
more of all persons some odd somehow
implausibly compressed together into a
notional unity reason because it seeks
structure determinacy and even certitude
where the rat approves available while
the demos because it's presumed follow
its own will by the light of its own
mind repudiates any structure or
determinacy which lies beyond the scope
of that will or the fitful illumination
of that mind and is ill-equipped to
muster certitude on any issue of real
consequence under democracy the damask
ultimately authorizes or be authorizes
law and it monitors and adjudicates the
claims of reason to interpret what that
law is and requires it does so
predominantly through a body of legal
specialists who have who may have middle
cognitive respect for or imaginative
sympathy with the great majority of
their fellow citizens except where those
citizens are playing a part within its
rituals long hallowed by custom as for
example de jure over most of the dead
web of constraint and guidance through
which law falls upon individual members
of the society therefore the authority
of the Dimas if present at all hovers
very far back and seldom or never makes
itself felt directly it's not because we
value or expect legality not because we
wish law to rule or confidently expect
it to prove able to that we've chosen
democracy as the one ground on which we
can accept subjection or at least accept
it to that very conditional degree to
which any of us genuinely do embrace our
own subjection other people's subjection
may be unbalanced reassuring but who
could rejoice at their own democracy
isn't the rule of law it doesn't ensure
it and it's still far from clear that it
may not in the end even precluded the
rule of law still more evidently isn't
democracy its attractions aren't those
of democracy its irritations aren't
those of democracy its dangers aren't
those of democracy but most each of
those two is a distinct partial good
with every potentiality to conflict'
with the other on the whole today we
probably value legality on balance quite
a lot more than we do democracy since
its benefits were available of both more
salient and quite a lot more reliable
almost anyone sooner or later can see
and feel the advantages of retaining
their own property rights however modest
in scope within the framework of the
existing law point obviously depending
on by Charles the first where it offers
advantages the advantages of legality
are immediate and comfortingly personal
they make REIT they accrue to each of
those to whom they do accrue just what
the net advantages of democracy are by
contrast remains an altogether more
speculative judgment requiring the
assessment of very intricate cause
but a considerable distance from the
life and experience of any given
individual as Hobbs flamboyantly
insisted almost anyone's personal
experience of democracy in action is
bound sooner or later to come out
acutely disconcerting what's true
however and what's a very great moment
in understanding democracy's percent is
that in numerous settings across the
world and most of all in this great
state democracy has come to be accepted
and understood as the content and basis
of an existing regime in which to a
significant degree law does rule not of
course through its own inherent power
since it doesn't have any but by the
more or less grudging consent of those
who do in fact do so at the very least
most contemporary advocates or partisans
of democracy believe it largely
compatible in practice with the rule of
law not a few of them also assume it in
defiance of logic or conceptual clarity
to enjoy an elective affinity with the
rule of law just as they assume it to
enjoy one with the causal dynamics of
normative presuppositions of a
capitalist economy those assumptions
severally and together are as you all
noticed
deeply lodged in the political tradition
and ideological sensibility of the
United States but considered soberly in
the abstract and on their own terms
they make singularly little sense over
most of the Earth's inhabited surface
they are very far from capturing the
intimations or carrying the authority of
such residues of tradition as remain in
working order and they can't even begin
to explain why democracy as an idea or
even a slogan can possess the momentum
to establish the right to govern for
anyone at all still less to generate the
to govern effectively anywhere where
that capacity isn't already amply in
evidence in very many different respects
America's espousal of democracy is not a
hermeneutic aid to fathoming how the
rest of the world sees and hears and
feels the meaning of that intensely
political concept for one thing it
confounds systematically and sometimes
quite purposefully a very drastic
process of power with a competition for
Allegiance between political ideas the
process of power was one in which a
temporarily uniquely rich and potent
society settled to the project of
remaking the world in its own image as
China's Emperor's had done on their own
impressive historical stage were very
considerably longer the process of power
was real enough in its yet to reach a
decisive end but the competition for
Allegiance between political ideas was
always somewhat illusory a Hegelian
shadowplay of flickering images of far
more elusive struggles between varyingly
frank and confused individuals and
political groupings it was in and
through those struggles that democracy
as a political conception or slogan has
scrabbled up the cliff of history the
question to press is just what it is
offered to those who have chosen to take
it up and why when and where they have
done so they've seen and felt it to
carry those offers if you see the
historical canvas of democracies ascent
in those terms it's clear at once that
what it depicts superimposes and
intersects very different sorts of
process each with their own distinctive
causalities you can if you want envisage
it as a single process defined by and in
part orchestrated through the spatial
passage and temporal vicissitudes of
this single word
and the prodigious proliferation of
human experience that swarmed around it
as its moved forward and outwards from
its very distant Greek starting point
that's history as pageantry with all its
terrors and exhilarations intact but to
see it that way isn't only
overwhelmingly beyond my own poetry
competence it's not at all to capture
how I wanted to see it the two questions
I want to press are firstly just what is
the political meaning of that special
passage and those temporal vicissitudes
what are their political implications
and secondly just why have they occurred
as and when they have what explains
their occurrence if you superimpose the
two stories you can't see either clearly
if you fail to recognize their causal
intersection you condemn yourself to
misjudging what does explain them and
you are all too likely to misunderstand
their political implications so to
recognize that is to register I think a
genuine methodological dilemma but it
isn't necessarily to reach an epistemic
and pass political in this understanding
insofar as it's available at all and so
far as politics really is intelligible
even in principle subsists in and must
confine itself to a rather more modest
epistemic register the frame in which I
want to persuade you to recognize what's
happened in democracy's erratic global
ascent is the continuous interaction of
two distinct dimensions each a decisive
abstraction from the full giddy pageant
and trauma of history both have
prominent idealist elements as history
is burned to if you focus hard and
steadily enough on it both cut past
continuously through the dynamics of the
human mind in operation and must be
recognized to depend on doing so
if they're to be understood at all
neither has any trace of the ethereal
this setting of Democracies ascent is in
the first place that global history of
human political experiences face their
magnitude complexity and opacity of
which none of us can steadily
contemplate or hope to take him but
within the cumulative residues of which
all of us are now condemned and
privileged to live better for worse for
richer for poorer in sickness and in
health till death do us part that's the
stage of every human life now there's
nowhere beyond it or outside it no
dependable historical or geographical
privacy left a lot of democracies own
instability and opacity as a political
category or even as a political
phenomenon now issues from its being so
unmistakably at the heart of that
relentless elimination of seclusion many
anywhere in the world must view
democracy's presence or prospective
arrival with misgivings and few anywhere
can be wholly confident a very important
right at the moment can be wholly
confident that it offers them any
personal guarantee of safety prosperity
or existential reassurance but no regime
in the world today anywhere where there
recognizably is a regime now inhabited
space which has escaped the state of
nature
is immune to the need to address itself
this term however open and uninhibited
the antipathy with which it views it
it's easy to see the passage of the word
itself was meaninglessly epiphenomena an
immense for a tiller of tiny quarks
bobbing helplessly around and the great
deluge of human experience but that I
I'm trying to convince you isn't a
politically perceptive judgment both
word and category are far more tightly
woven into the fabric
this unfolding story they catch and
carry too much feeling and judgment and
shape far too much active political
purpose as it moves towards the present
whatever proves to be true in the future
even if democracy is a political
category or value will somehow to be
extirpated from every human community in
centuries ahead the political space
within which that outcome could arise
and the political agents who would bring
it about would by now be quite largely
creatures of its prior passage as a
category all that is just to remind you
perhaps rather melodramatically of the
huge state we all now held in
understanding the provenance of the term
as we see and hear and feed it today and
the dynamics and weight of the
experience that's given it that grip on
us the second dimension is less hectic
the new tone and perhaps also
analytically more tractable if the first
focuses perforce on the experience
political social and economic of
stupefying numbers of human beings
the second concentrates on a domain
where political scientists can feel more
at home on political struggle itself and
more particularly on the vicissitudes of
political concepts within political
struggle what matters there for my
purposes isn't the incidence of
political struggle the forms it assumes
the range of participants it pulls into
it or even its outcomes and what causes
those outcomes to eventuate as they do
not come out quite differently instead
it's what political struggle discloses
about political concepts themselves the
dimension I want to capture is the
respect in which political struggle
constitutes and operates as a set of
heuristics for political concepts
testing inexorably their realism clarity
normative insight and potential to shape
goals
and consolidate purposes for possible
allies and subvert the power and deplete
the will of possible or actual
adversaries that too is the space in
which democracy has won so very recently
its giddy global eminence fiercely
contested throughout but then in this
war space is no concept could ever save
me a spark to move beyond contest it's
in that space above all that democracy
is most unmistakably shown itself
unmatched in the power to recruit allies
and quell rifles in face of every other
category so far defined in the history
of human speech if you see those two
dimensions as we plainly should as twin
facets of a single integrated causal
story it's clear at once that the
relative analytical tract ability of the
second is important that democracy has
won its present eminence in and through
the global history of human political
experience is I think just a truism but
the truth it expresses is overwhelming
the abstract and the infinite array of
concrete causalities it infos could
never be clearly known to any human
being much of it is now irrecoverably
lost and what might still be recovered
play the entire epistemic domain of
modern political science past present
and year future is the most unpromising
guide to the whole if the heuristic
which has established democracy
superiority in the present epoch in
realism clarity and potential the shape
girls and consolidate purposes for
potential allies and weaken and
demoralize prospective adversaries has
been political struggle itself it must
be right to see democracies global
comparative advantage in the breadth of
the field over which it can solicit
identification and the relative
narrowness of the space its pre
condemned to exclude
as elicit nefarious or actively malign
that was essentially the appeal of the
abbe de ses to the Third Estate of the
ancien régime and it was also the claim
to Authority he advanced on their behalf
unlike the partisans of monarchical
power or the open champions of
aristocracy the political nation as
seers conceived it was pre committed to
excluding only those who chose to
exclude themselves from it
those who claimed and fully meant to
stand above the law it evoked invoked
and recognized and freed themselves from
the constraints that law imposed by
determining its content uninhibitedly
for themselves in a temporary vacuum of
authority they couldn't readily be a
wider appeal within a given space for a
given population there the political
balance would of course be affected by
the numbers of those who claim the
privilege the breadth of an appeal of
course is no index of its credibility
its share power to induce belief and by
that measure democracy has been there
more charismatic than any other
political category but by that measure
it's hard to see how any political
category could be charismatic in the
inner office in and of itself and how
even those categories most historically
efficacious in inducing belief in one
context could hope to sustain it as the
context changed as all political
contexts do sooner or later if the
identification reappear of democracy is
personal and purposefully indiscriminate
in the persons it chooses to address
that breadth and lack of the
fastidiousness could be an orphan has
been lethally repellent to those best
place to defend themselves but leveled
indefinitely and repeatedly over ever
larger spaces its lengthening sequence
of particular defeats has been
increasingly out where
by its rule political appeal it's hard
to see how any rival could press its
personal appeal more widely or less
discriminating ly or offset a narrower
and more discriminating person will
address by anything other than
consistently proven efficacy
unnecessarily vulnerable title to power
in any human setting the human world
hasn't come to embrace democracy in the
muddled partial halting manner in which
it now gars because it's come to believe
in democracy as a solid and reliable
foundation for authority but because
it's come increasingly to disbelieve in
any other sort of human basis on which
to do so and to distrust compulsively
over time all humanly mediated claims to
ground it on some Supra human basis we
shouldn't see democracies global ascent
as a stunning triumph of credulity or a
majestic forward march of justified true
belief but simply as an uneven reluctant
painful series of surrenders of an
immense miscellany of other kinds of
belief that's so familiar enough picture
plausibly associated with some elements
of the European enlightenment whatever
you think that was or wasn't but it's
easy enough to recognize that the
picture it offers isn't that of the
Enlightenment as didactic would-be
mentor to mankind but as nervous profit
of the Chile landscape to come if you
see democracies are sent in that more
disabused perspective you couldn't same
lease oppose whatever else it does or
suffers or seem forced to yield unto in
the centuries to come that democracy is
a synonym for good government under
democracy we may be lucky enough to
experience good government but good
government isn't something we're
entitled to expect either normatively or
epistemic ly
under democracy the responsibility for
assessing how far government is in fact
good plainly doesn't rest principally on
the government either as a discrete
actor or a miscellany of varyingly
coherent agencies instead it falls on
the citizens at large and the
responsibility for amending its
aberrations also in the end falls
unrelentingly on those same citizens as
a whole it's rude for a foreign visitor
to say such things but it's also I think
incumbent on them to tell the truth as
they see it as it looks at present to a
foreign eye from China or Iran or Burma
or Switzerland or Germany or Norway or
even from England it's hard to see the
citizenry of the United States at
present as especially successful in
furnishing themselves with good
government under their uniquely
time-tested and elastic Democratic
formula I don't want to suggest that
that protected and passed is somehow
democracy's fault merely that democracy
of all political formula requires each
of us to try to understand why such
outcomes arise and why they sometimes
persist with such apparent obstinacy
under democracy
unlike most other political Rubik you
can't blame that outcome merely on the
temporary and contingent ascendancy of
the nefarious or congenitally foolish we
the people are the nefarious and the
foolish every bit as much as the fine
and the wise when we choose badly we
have no one to blame but ourselves once
we start to quarrel and of course we
never actually stop quarreling about
just who is wise or foolish virtuous or
any intentioned the common frame of
identification and the authorization it
provides drop away and we're left with
very little but our mutual antipathies
and contempt